يعني في فتره الطفوله وفتره المراهقه عشنا
فتره ذهبيه بالنسبه لمركز الفنون
التشكيليه يعني
كل المواضيع اللي بتخطر على بالي
والحميميه والقريبه عليه كنت ارسمها انه
مثل النواعير باب النهر مواضيع من حماه
القبض تبع السفيره يعني
[موسيقى]
حلوه
كنت اشتغل بالنهار اكثر من 10 ساعات
يعني سن 14 سنه ايه صار هاجسي الفن
بالنسبه
كان كثير مو هون
وكانوا يعطونا من المدرسه مواد والوان
ولوحات ويدعموني الحلو يعني احتضروك هذه
الموهبه احتضنوني يعني بس بالصدفه يعني
صارت انه رجعت انا صار حسان
من فتره
الاداء الابتدائي
انه ما بقدر يصرف فعلينا نحن بدنا 13 شخص
الى 10 شخص وبعدين صرنا 13 يعني كان يشتغل
بتنجيده وبيصيد السمك
[موسيقى]
يظل جاهل يعني
يمكن
يريح ضميره سالني شو حمود هي معي الدوسه
بدك المدرسه ولا الشغل
فكرت
انا اشتغل
المعجون ورق جدران ودهان قلت له لا
المدرسه خلال خمس دقائق قررت
وكملته وغيرت حياتي وطموحي 180 درجه يعني